Fusion is an amazing process that
happens in the middle of stars where
small nuclei of atoms join together to
make bigger ones and release copious
amounts of energy and we hope to be able
to harness that physics and that
technology associated with it to make
power here on earth fusion might be the
perfect source of energy because we have
millions of years worth of fuel it's
safe it's um it's clean the catch is
that as you know it's one of the most
difficult science and engineering
challenges ever undertaken
so if you want to do fusion you've got
to get a temperature of about 200
million degrees and to do that you've
got to hold your fuel in a cage of
magnetic field Andrei Sakharov the
Russian dissident had in the 1950s the
most successful design which is called
the tokamak and the tokamak is a cajun
magnetic field in the shape of a ring
doughnut in a spherical talked about
what we do is we squash that plasma down
into something that looks more like a
cored Apple so you've only got now a
small hole in the center of the plasma
and what that does is it obviously makes
the fusion system a bit more compact but
what's less obvious it allows us to get
to very high values of plasma pressure
compared to the pressure of the magnetic
field that's confining the plasma and
the higher the magnetic pressure the
more fusion reactions that you get as
you look around the world today there is
a surge in the interest in spherical
tokamak rendering a very exciting time
here at PPL and at NS DX this enormous
team of engineers and physicists and
technicians have just about finished
constructing the NS DXF great facility
there's two key components to this
upgrade project one is to replace some
of the magnets not all but some with
larger more high-power magnets that one
able to apply higher field strengths for
longer pulses the other upgrade is to
double the amount of power we have we'll
be able to make plasmas with more
current that are hotter with more power
going in for longer pulses we intend to
make our test plasma that would
Commission the facility in the next
month to month and a half if you're
producing copious amounts of heat in a
small volume because these are much
smaller devices you'll gain have an
exhaust problem your resource is going
to be too intense and so the mass device
and NS Tio's are testing out different
ideas to cope with that very powerful
exhaust we modify the magnetic fields
outside the plasma to divert that plasma
the particles are going around a lot
further along the magnetic field and
therefore they lose more energy as they
go so you end up with less energy
arriving spread out over a larger area
we're about halfway through the build
the original mass experiment came to an
end in 2013 it was sighted here as you
see in the pit
behind us we've stripped that out in
three months and ever since have been
pulling it into its various modules and
building these modules back up so that
we can assemble it into that operating
machine starting next year a tokamak
energy we're building small tokamak
switch our prototype each prototype has
its own goal
the first tokamak that we built which is
behind me was to demonstrate long pulses
in the in such a small device using
microwave power the next device were
built was more on engineering and we
used high-temperature superconductors in
this tokamak for the first time next
stage we're working at is high field a
spherical tokamak from the second half
of this century is where we will really
have challenges greatly enhanced in
mitigating carbon production and that's
where fusion will be critical to the
world and at that point we're going to
say okay we need a fusion reactor and we
need it by the middle of the century
we've got to push down the cost and
scale of those reactors so that when we
come to market it's cost-effective these
devices will do that
you